what gives you the right to grab me like
that
oh but yo you tripping what are you
saying
what'd you post
oh that it was time to talk about toxic
femininity
yeah but the thing is what you're saying
is that i ain't including [ __ ] i said
y'all are not ready to talk about it but
when i said y'all you really thought i
was talking about women i'm talking
about all of y'all
everybody nobody's really
ready to talk about [ __ ] because
everybody's gonna say some dumb [ __ ] no
but what it implies is that oh
oh and some some girl came on
in my dm is like yo what you wrote i
think it's really bizarre because like
coming from a girl coming from a girl
that suffered this and that and that
well and i was like well coming from a
guy that suffered this you know what
never mind i wrote that exactly oh i
didn't know that i didn't know that you
suffered that i'm sorry that you it
doesn't matter that's not the point the
point is that you don't want to yeah but
when you say like that it's like it's
denying everything that we no one
doesn't i'm not denying [ __ ] i'm not
saying that men are not toxic that men
are not doing some [ __ ] up [ __ ] and
that one does not negate the other you
know what i'm talking about talking
about what [ __ ] what women are doing is
not saying well i'm not saying well [ __ ]
what man is doing women are doing that's
not what i'm doing it's like hey we need
to also assess that and i gave the
example of whenever we see that there's
not enough black people and there's not
enough diversity in the media and i said
when people say that i go to my
communities and i'd be like hey you know
what yes there's not people there's not
enough of people that look like us in
the media but we have
to push our people to do that as well
because when it's going to be time to
jump it's going to be asking for people
nobody
you're here we have to push our children
into those spots but
whatever you know what i appreciate when
it comes to like men's issues and like
the whole gender stuff like you've
really taken up the mental i have a pain
in that whole fight oh yeah you gave up
i'm not i used to be me back in the day
because you died inside the long ass
time
it used to be me back
when we first started i used to be
indeed
yeah but the thing is i was not i'm not
right now as bad as you are i'm just
like ugh whatever no you you was [ __ ]
i was mad because
one i dealt with it on a first-hand
basis far more often
but two it was like i was living it in
the present in a lot of ways all the
time right yeah i'm leaving i'm living
in now yeah that's what i feel like
that's the thing your eyes have been
opened no because i'm living it now it's
like because you up you have a certain
especially in quebec since you know
i'm more known in quebec right
so because of that girls come up to me
and they do some foul [ __ ] yeah
and i'm like [ __ ] what gives you the
right you [ __ ] been talking all
this [ __ ] [ __ ] but when it comes to
you
you touch a [ __ ] you touch that
hair [ __ ] you touch your body oh
you bigger than that and then you're
gonna you're gonna grab a [ __ ]
and everything and stuff it's like you
was talking all this [ __ ]
for all these years and sometimes
[ __ ] that was loud about it yeah
talk about it i remember you [ __ ] in
the on on you was you was under social
media talking on [ __ ] and you were
about to find things what gives you the
right to grab me like that
oh but yo you tripping what are you
saying
and maybe because of the fact that she
was dating and you was chilling and
everything and all this [ __ ] and
everything stuff and you were chilling
and now it's kind of my position it's
kind of it's i'm in the dating world now
because it kind of propels me into that
position where it's kind of oh you're
getting the desirability you're having
even though you're not even trying to
i'm not putting you out there but you
understand what i'm saying do you want
to know why i am where i am where are
you at it's just two reasons
one i'm not in these streets
two i don't leave my home no you don't
so i don't have to deal with it i don't
got no social media so i don't have to
hear about their stupid opinions no more
i don't have to get triggered by none of
that [ __ ] okay i have to see the
dumb opinions that people have to send
me in regards to like because i'm just
not trying to hear it all right when it
comes to men's stuff they don't give a
flying [ __ ] they don't care at all so
enough to hear them not saying they
don't care just go live your life and
two i'm not out here really interacting
with women like that i keep my distance
i get my distance from people in general
because
the more time you spend out there the
more opportunities you've given for them
to violate your powers yeah whether you
like it or not yeah so it's just that
the difference is you was looking for
that [ __ ]
you were looking for interaction back
then
yeah because i was actively dating
and because of my status it's just out
there yeah
and you're also present though you're
out
at events you're doing hosting gigs
you're at corporates
when i do stuff like that and i post
stuff like when we're talking about
toxic femininity [ __ ] jump like
they really they really
it's like i said that [ __ ] and i was
it's like if i was an alien bruh
this is why i like winter this is why
the cold seasons [ __ ] i put up all the
hoodies i put up hoodies i put on face
masks i put on [ __ ] do-rags i hide my
whole face and i go why because i get to
keep my space from people
i get to keep my space from people
because people can be super weird don't
this
this is my ability to keep my distance
people like well we don't recognize you
trust me i got hoodies you've never seen
before so when i be out there a lot of
people don't recognize me i don't get
recognized that often no you don't wear
it when you're going out close and
you're inside no thank you no they're
not so so you have to find ways to like
keep your distance from people because
you see that stuff and you recognize
like people don't respect boundaries
whatsoever no they don't so
[ __ ] are [ __ ] up so it's like
it's just and the reason why i brought
it up is not it's not to overshadow what
women are going through women going
going through some [ __ ] up times right
now
it's [ __ ] up i think you're trying to
overshadow what they're doing because
right now the focus is on them and your
problems like we'll get to them later
there's a minor kill exactly that's
exactly what a [ __ ] said that's
exactly what a [ __ ] said he's
like no
it's not the time man shut your [ __ ]
mouth
shuts your [ __ ] mouth
so it's the same thing it's the same
thing as whenever you saw whenever there
was black people that was talking about
black lives matter people like oh people
are not ready you're the same dude
you're the same dude
cancer awareness month well right now
they got women's issues years okay well
they just got a whole decade just
dedicated to what the [ __ ] they going
through god damn it's like you you
[ __ ] were the one talking about
all this [ __ ] about my boundaries and
you were talking all this [ __ ] what
happened brother i knocked my tooth i
think i think it's karma for me
triggering you jesus was like he took my
ring and he slammed it there you go
there you go that's what happens
yeah you stalking all this smack all
these year about men this meant that and
i was all here for it i was like you
know what yes
yeah that's what it is yeah
man
people should be accountable and then
you pull this [ __ ]
the [ __ ] are [ __ ] up
gaslighting and [ __ ] yeah and when and
when when you tell and when you tell a
[ __ ] they try to downplay like
it
hey if you don't get the [ __ ] out of
here
i got no more energy for that by the way
let
yeah it just hit me get rid of facebook
let us know what you guys think of the
comments oh fake i'm done i'm [ __ ]
done with this [ __ ]